all right
Tamara tamarrow where are you from where
where'd you grow up Harford
Connecticut tell me about your family
growing up um so growing up I had a
pretty good childhood at least I thought
at first for the most part it was okay I
was adopted at 9 months old um and I was
adopted into a African-American family
and that's all the family I have known
for most part they are my family it was
seven of us all together and
um and you know it was fun with holidays
and parties and things of that nature
but um you know every family have there
ups and downs and problems
that a lot of times are not spoken of
and growing up um I was raped and
molested you know from 7 to 13 years old
from what I could remember
and um that was in their family yes and
I never said anything because I was told
that if I didn't I would have to go I
would go back to DCF and that was scary
for me being a kid and um so I never
said anything until I was 36 years old
and
um even still like it's still as if it
never happened
but my mom always told me that you
um sorry forgive but you never forget so
that's what I'm working on now it's
trying to like forget but I will never
forget it you know how old are you now
41 41 so just a few years
ago like when I was 36 so that's when I
first like spoke of it so um it's still
hard because
like I I told like my siblings like um
to not give that person like my number
and stuff and he still like did so
that's why like um to this day I won't
have like a at
all sorry cuz I want him to contact me
at
all um other than that um well and on
top of that as I got older
um he started me on um perco setes and
um like
the baby one he call it and then the
oxycotton and I took it because it made
me feel better it made me forget or it
made me you know feel high and uh not
think about the stuff that happened so
um and then from that he actually uh
gave me cocaine uh to start sniffing and
um I like that too was this one of your
adopted Brothers
mhm and
um so I constantly took it from them
because uh it it took the pain away and
it made me feel good but then in 2012 I
um had a back injury and I hurt my own
back I hurt my back so um I was getting
you know my own pills um and then I had
to go to pain management so I was
getting a lot of pills and stuff and
then I decided one day before I knew
about anything about withdraw I took the
pills one day a half a bottle and I
poured them down the toilet cuz I just
was done with the whole pill thing and
then like hours later I just felt so
sick and I like wanted to bring my head
on a wall so I caught my best friend at
the time and ask him like what was
happening to me and I told him what I
did and he told me to come to his house
but he said he didn't have any pills so
he's like what I have I don't want to
give you because you're just going to
want need more of it so then I was like
I don't give basically at this point I
don't give a d what it is just give it
to me and it was Herman and uh he gave
me that and I started sniffing that and
then um basically
like since I end up so I I I popped
dirty um in Pay management so they
basically kick me out but they we me off
and then after that like I'm like I
can't just go through I don't like the
way this feels so I um I started just
using you know off the street
and then um at that time her room was
becoming less available and F all showed
up so my ex-boyfriend um he's my
boyfriend at the time that's all he
could find so he got the fit andlaw and
um we started using that and then when I
tried to go back to her when it wasn't
strong enough so
um it I just started doing I've been on
it for almost 3 years now and I never
thank God I never o and I never do
enough to not out I just do enough so I
won't be
sick and then that's part like um I have
two daughters and I always said to said
to myself I won't ever do to my
daughters with the what the lady that
had me did to me which is you know them
being born addicted or being on drugs
and neglecting them and I
did so I'm not happy about that um
I got a 15-year-old daughter and a
four-year-old daughter and my
15-year-old I know she's mad and
disappointed with me
so I'm like too afraid to contact her
and my four-year-old doesn't know
anything now so I have time but it's
like when am I going to do
it so but I came out here for a
program that's why I came over in
California because it supposed to be the
best program ever and it wasn't
so I'm at the point of trying to decide
now if I stay here and find a program or
go home and do a
program what are you using currently um
f law and
crack and where you
staying on streets homeless you're in a
tent or just on the street on the
street how long has that that's been
going on um I've been here since
and
um basically like when I first got to
the
program uh it wasn't what it was
supposed to be like everything I saw in
brochures and online and it freaked me
out so that the next day I left and then
after a week I went back and um I stayed
for like a month or so something like
that and then they discharged me because
I relapsed and when I went back to the
house I had my drug still on me and
wanted to throw them away and I would I
didn't want them to throw them away cuz
I'm like I to spend my money on them so
I'll go out and use finish it but you're
not throwing my stuff away so she uh the
one of the house managers was like
saying in my business in front of the
other clients which wasn't professional
and I felt embarrassed so I I walked off
the property and then when I came back
they said because I walked off the
property they discharged me and um and
they whole nothing with insurance but so
it's basically been over a month now
I've been living like on streets but
trying to figure out what to do
[Music]
next you feel like what happened to you
as a young girl kind of redirected your
life yes and I feel like it I always say
it ruined my like my life because no
matter what like even being in before I
came here I was in a 15 year
relationship with my ex um and before
that like like as far as like being
sexual any relationship I hate it even
to this day um it it messed up my life
and I feel like in every aspect because
it made me like the person who I am
which is like I'm out more outspoken now
like maybe years ago I probably wouldn't
never did this interview because I was
so shy and scared but my ex actually
helped me with that he's like you can't
keep letting people like just beat up on
you and you got to get stronger so like
I don't let people do that to new work
but it's always going to be there
because I can't take that like that part
out of my life no matter how much I try
to forgive it it's there like it it
ruined my life I feel like um
so I I feel like at the end of the day
like I'm always going to need something
to
like help me with what happened and the
only thing I've helped that helped so
far is drugs and a lot of people think
it's excuses but it's it's not like it's
it's a truth for me so um until I can
find something else that helps me I'm
going to continue to do what I do and a
lot of people say well your daughter
should mean enough to you to stop and
they should but they don't and not I
love my daughter's to death but
sometimes people go think like
that be other people understand and I
don't think people understand
that you're trying to escape the pain
from what you went
exactly and that's the only thing that
has helped me so far and my daughters
well they they mean them everything in
the world to me but I just hope that
nothing like that ever happened to them
you know um so they don't have to know
how this
feels what's what's the hardest part of
this lifestyle for
you you must get depressed I would think
yeah yeah depression and being anxious
all the time like I can't sit still like
I move around all the time my mind is
constantly thinking um it's just hard I
don't like living like this and then
it's like trying to find you know money
to buy the things I need how do you make
money
um a lot sometimes a pan handle which I
suck at because everyone says like but
you're not talking about loud enough and
I can't hear you or I'm not proud of
this but I have done uh
of some sex acts to get money to support
my habit which I'm not proud of but I
had to do it to not be sick or feel sick
you know I don't like feeling like with
Jos but at the end of the day I did what
I had to do or I do what I have to do um
a lot of it is not some of it is not
positive but I
mean I try to make it more like not
about like doing it like any
prostitution stuff as blessed as I can
and just P handle you know that way or
um my since I've been here my
ex-boyfriend has helped me out a few
times sending me money um because he
doesn't want me to be sick he know what
the money is for so he's like I know
he's stuck because we basically like our
relationship ended because he was clean
and I wasn't but he was forced to get
clean because he he went to jail and um
for eight months and he did everything
and I had to figure everything out for
the first time and I lost 100 lb when he
was in jail and um and it's crazy
because I'm over here I'm making sure I
have money to send him not even
supporting or helping myself you know
and and then when he got out he was mad
that I didn't go to a program and I said
you've been ad over 40 years of your
life cuz he's 64 you should know out of
all people that you can't tell anybody
when they ready to get clean I know when
I'm ready and the more he told me the
more I did the
opposite so um that's basic basically
why like uh we we basically broke up uh
because he couldn't show me the support
I showed him and I didn't think that was
fair and I I understand but at the same
time I don't like I would never
jeopardize his sobriety but at the same
time like even talking to me on the
phone would be supportive enough for me
but he could wouldn't do that have you
ever seen a therapist yeah the last
therapist I saw was like um 2019 and it
freaked me out because I got all the way
to the point of um and I actually got my
younger daughter back I went to a woman
Children's Program and I got her back
and a week before DCF was going to be
out of our Lives I relapsed um we almost
us we almost di died in an apartment
fire so I couldn't take that you know
like um mentally but um the therapist
was doing it wasn't hypnotizing me it
was I forgot what it's called but it was
uh something she was doing it it was to
make me remember the things that
happened and she thought it would be a
good idea and and it got to the point
where I would start remembering these
things and I got worse like I I wanted
to like get myself because I couldn't
take remembering things I didn't knew
happened like I knew happened to me but
I blocked it out for so long it wanted
to forget I it it was out of my mind but
then when she was doing these things it
started coming back so I stopped
going um how does talking about it now
affect you
like I I honestly like even though
crying and stuff like it's it's I feel
I'm like my heart doesn't feel as heavy
right now as it will feel before and I
feel like because like I know I have
like even though like to him of course
no one's going to sit there and say they
did these things or whatever to me I
have no reason to lie about St I have no
reason to my whole life was Ru I
have two col degrees I I went to
University I graduated in 2006 I'm not
doing nothing with any of my degrees
like why why would I just throw my life
away like that for no reason so he
considered to say it didn't happen
but even when my mom passed away um he
tried he was trying to pay give me like
$300 to not say anything because I don't
know maybe he just felt like at some
point it was going to come up and I I
didn't take the
money I walked away
y what's what's your biggest
regret not telling my mom when you were
young
yeah
yeah not telling her and not scking up
for myself like you with the kid I felt
like maybe like as I got older
like 12 and 13 I should have push my
like try to skate more you know instead
of just saying oh well if I say if I
escape and tell then I got I'm going to
have to leave his family I should have
not listened to him so I regret that
what's your greatest
strength I feel like sticking up for
myself cuz I always like let everyone
bully me down to my family you know and
I don't know like I don't do that
anymore I stick for myself I I love
myself more now even though a lot of
times it might not seem that way but I
do
like just
being there for me and and hoping that
one day
that I will be able to get off drugs I'm
always going to be addict it's just
whether I choose to pick up or not so
I'm hoping one day soon that I can like
decide whether I'm going to continue to
be I feel like I I can't even answer
that because I don't I could stop and
then I could always relapse at any point
in time
I feel like it's always going to be hard
for me this the way my life ended up is
always going to be hard like people look
at it like me being adopted was the best
thing yes it was the best thing but they
don't know the inside details of it so
because of that I feel like I'm always
going to have a hard time like the other
day like I was going to
withdraw and and it's because of what
I'm trying to do is let my body like as
soon as I feel the first withdrawals
symptom don't go to use like try to
stick it out more and I was trying to
stick it out and and I honestly said I
was like I wish I just die now like I
won't feel any pain anymore like I'm
just TI everything so like I I I really
felt that way one day last week like I
didn't want to live anymore
but I know if if I really wanted that I
could you know whatever but so I know I
really don't want it because I I didn't
do anything to make that happen you know
know it just hard a lot of times
especially being out here not knowing
anybody and then to me a lot of people
out here are
mean um like even me asking for
directions like going mean so I think
that's it too like they say I haven't
found the right people or been in around
the right places
yet what's what's your greatest fear
now
um is me passing away and my family not
knowing about it or like not KN what
happened to me and like me just
like
um like disappearing the near and like
my feeling on without me have you o de
nope in 3 years I've been up here all
and I never e and and I never like get
enough to KN out because I just
like do enough to not feel sick and then
even if I get it from the same person I
still do the same thing I just take do a
little bit because you don't know how
that batch is you know so I'm scared of
that I actually um my ex OD the one I
was with before I came here and I
brought them back I always carryed nans
with me and um because I'm I don't want
to see anybody o and die off of it all
tomarrow what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life um the most important lesson in my
life
um I feel like
um I feel like sticking to to what I say
I'm going to do
like I've been like this has made me a
big procrastinated too I don't know like
why a lot of the thing is like I I did a
lot like I love to please my mom like my
my mom that adopted me and and um I
think when she passed away I didn't have
anybody to please anymore or really help
anymore so I feel like I became like
a uh I don't know I want to say couch
potato but I feel like
um I just feel like I I would have did
something different as far as like
keeping up with things like jobs and
stuff like that you know and um go going
back to school sooner cuz I like making
decisions on that like I wanted to get
my masters but I feel like now I'm to
the point where I feel like I'm being
too old to do that so I would say like
just do doing what needs to be done and
entirely man and stop putting things off
cuz I I put it off to the point where it
don't get
done just like me saying I got to figure
out if I'm going to stay here and do a
program or go home like I should have
been figured that out by now but it's
like I don't know what's stopping me
it's like I'm afraid to get clean
because then I felt like I'm not going
to have anything to make me feel better
anymore all right tomarrow thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you I
hope you figure out a way to get out of
this I hope so too thank you very much
for listening to
me